رده
فعل دوله اسرائيل والجيش الاسرائيلي كانت
رده فعل قويه اللي ادت الى ضحايا اضافيين
من المدنيين
باعداد كبيره هذه الارقام تتحدث عن ذلك
وانا في اعتقادي انه الامر نابع من حجم
ال
الاحداث المؤسفه التي كانت في غلاف غزه
قتل حوالي 1200 اسرائيلي معظمهم مدنيون
ولكن في نهايه الامر يعني على الجانب
الاسرائيلي ان يدرك ان القوه العسكريه في
نهايه الامر لم تستطع ان تحمي المدنيين
الاسرائيليين في غلاف غزه كما في كما ان
القوه العسكريه او المسلحه للفصائل
الفلسطينيه جلبت الدمار لقطاع غزه
وضحايا كثيرون اطفال ونساء فلسطينيين
بمعنى ان منطق القوه ومنطق التعامل
العسكري فقط اثاره وخيمه وسيول كراهيه
وغضب في الطرفين يستمر لسنوات طويله فلا
الجيش الاسرائيلي استطاع ان يحمي
المواطنين ولا الفصائل المسلحه استطاعت ان
تجلب حل سلمي للفلسطينيين ولذلك يجب
الاحتكام الى منطق السياسه السلميه والسعي
الى الحلول السلميه وليس
الحرب
لا الحكومه الاسرائيليه والجيش الاسرائيلي
عليهم ان يبذلوا جهد اكبر لمنع عنف
المستوطنين وهذا مصلحه اسرائيليه بالدرجه
الاولى لانه عمليا يمنع فتح جبهه حرب
جديده ايضا في الضفه الغربيه ومن جهه اخرى
لاحظ ان السلطه الفلسطينيه والرئيس محمود
عباس يبذلون جهدا كبيرا لمنع التصعيد في
الضفه الغربيه والرئيس محمود عباس يعني
يتحلى بموقف عقلاني وشجاع ويتمسك بالحل
السلمي
ويدعم التنسيق الامني لمنع العنف بين
الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين وبالتالي يجب دعم موقف
الرئيس عباس والسلطه الفلسطينيه من اجل
تمكين السلطه من ايه ايه يعني ان تفرض
سيطرتها في الضفه الغربيه وايضا في
المستقبل القريب في قطاع غزه ونبدا من
جديد مسار الوصول الى تسويه سياسيه وحل
نهائي لهذا الصراع واحلال السلام لذلك انا
اعتقد رغم
انه رئيس الحكومه بنيامين نتنياهو خلال
السنوات الماضيه سعى الى اضعاف الرئيس
الفلسطيني محمود عباس الا انه الرئيس
محمود عباس مازال يت حل بالقوه والشجاعه
هو والفريق
الرئاسي ويتصرفون بمسؤوليه لمنع تصعيد
جديد في الضفه
الغربيه
للاسف الصراع الموجود الان هنا والحرب
الدائره الان تؤثر على
جميع الاتجاهات ودول العالم ونحن نرى ان
المزيد من الجهات والجماعات في الولايات
المتحده وفي غير الو المتحده يتاثرون بهذا
الصراع ويتجهون باتجاهات مرفوضه ومدان
دائي للجميع لمن يؤيد دوله اسرائيل ولمن
يؤيد الشعب
الفلسطيني خارج البلاد مهم جدا ان نلتزم
بالخطاب والتوجه السلمي وان تكون شعاراتنا
التي نرفعها دائما في اتجاه احلال السلام
وحل الصراع وتج وتجنب
العنف المتبادل في اي حاله من ال في اي
حاله من الاوال لا مبرر للعنف ضد اي انسان
هذا يجب ان يكون خط دائم لنا جميعا وان
نتقبل بعضنا البعض اهم قيمه يجب ان نتعامل
فيها هنا في داخل الارض المقدسه فلسطين
واسرائيل هي قيمه التسامح والقبول بالاخر
وحق بالعيش بامن وكرامه وسلام وايضا الناس
في العالم يجب ان يدعموا هذا التوجه وان
يتصرفوا بتسامح وبقبول بالاخر سواء لبس
الكوفيه الفلسطينيه او لبس القبعه
اليهوديه هذا هو الحل الوحيد
الواقعي في هذه المرحله حل الدولتين يضمن
للفلسطينيين حق تقرير المصير وقيام دوله
فلسطينيه ويضمن للاسرائيليين
امن دوله اسرائيل كدوله يهوديه ديمقراطيه
هذان هما الهدفان
للشعبين الفلسطيني والاسرائيلي فقط حل
الدولتين هو الذي يعطي هذا الهدف للطرفين
وبالتالي نعم احنا ما زلنا متمسكين بحل
الدولتين ولكن نحن بحاجه الى دور امريكي
قوي في المنطقه وفاعل يعني امريكا احضرت
قوات عسكريه هنا لمنع توسع الحرب انا
اقترح ايضا على الاداره الامريكيه ان ترسل
بعثه دبلوماسيه دائمه الى المنطقه تشتغل
فقط في مساله حل الصراع والوصول الى حل
الدولتين